tu ne peux pas te présenter ici sans
prévenir quoi de neuf est-ce qu'il s'est passé quelque chose
oui
nicholas est venu vivre avec moi et
il s'améliore mais il est un peu fragile
la façon dont il est venu me voir tu me blâmes
pour ce qui s'est passé
il est différent de  les autres qu'est-ce
qui te fait dire
pourquoi tu ne me réponds pas je te réponds
le regard dans ses yeux est dérangeant elle
veut nous monter les uns contre les autres
[Musique
] à l'époque il y a tellement de joie dans notre
famille je me sens comme un  échec si
je suis comme ça c'est de ta faute qu'est-ce que
j'ai fait c'est de ma faute n'ai-je pas toujours
tout fait pour toi j'ai le droit
de réinventer ma vie c'est ma vie
tout va bien à la maison
ouais
tout va bien
toi